you're out morale was a very simple
situation I owned a property in Florida
I was gonna do it at no cost or give it
free if I got a ruling because as a
question as to whether or not you're
allowed to give it because it's like a
contribution to a country I'd have to
get a ruling but I would have given it
for nothing it's a lot of a lot of money
I wouldn't give in a way like I give
away my salary I give away my salary
it's I guess close to four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars I gave it away
nobody ever said he gives away salary
now it comes up because of this but I
give away my presidential salary they
say that no other president has done it
I'm surprised to be honest with you they
actually say that George Washington may
may have been the only other president
but see whether or not Obama gave up his
salary see whether or not all of the
other of your favorites came up this
salary the answer is no they say it's
the only one they think George
Washington did but they say no so I give
up a lot of money four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars close to and I give
that up so I have a place that's in the
best location I'm very good at real
estate very very good much better do you
even understand when you see my
financials which I'll give at the right
time you'll say man he was much better
than we even thought this guy knows
right here minuchin because he was in
the private sector he does he knows very
much what I have he would tell you
someday maybe he'll tell you but I'm
very good at real estate
there's Miami this facility everybody
would have had their own building
everybody in the g7 would have had their
own building it was so good Florida
loved it they loved economic development
it's it's not because it's a it's a
beautiful place it's new it's been
totally rebuilt it's no everything's
good got massive meeting rooms unlimited
for security because it's on you know
hundreds of acres best location right
next to the airport Miami International
one of the biggest airports in the world
some people say it's the biggest but one
of the biggest airports in the world
it's only minutes away it would have
been great but the Democrats went crazy
even though I would have done it free
save the country a lot of money then
they say oh but you'll get promotion
it you don't think I get enough
promotion I get more promotion than any
human being that's ever lived and I
think I can I think I would have that I
think I can say that fairly safe yeah I
think I get more promotion than any
human being that's ever lived some good
some bad the people that likely give me
only good to people that don't like
making the only bit but that's the way
life is
I don't need promotion in a promotion
okay but I was willing to do this for
free and they would it would have been
the greatest g7 ever and I would have
said to my family because they run my
business now I don't run my business I
actually put all the stuff in trusts
they run by and I didn't have to do that
but under no obligation you know I don't
know if you know George Washington he
ran his business simultaneously while he
was president many other presidents
there weren't too many really rich
presidents but there were a few they ran
their business hey Obama made a deal for
a book is that running a business I I'm
sure he didn't even discuss it while he
was president yeah he has a deal with
Netflix when did they start talking
about that that's only you know a couple
of examples but other presidents if you
look other presidents were wealthy not
huge wealth George Washington was
actually considered a very very rich man
at the time but they ran their
businesses George Washington they say
had two desks he had a presidential desk
and a business desk I don't think you
people with this phoney of monuments
laws and by the way I would say that
it's cost me anywhere from two to five
billion dollars to be president and
that's okay between what I lose in what
I could have made I would have made a
fortune if I just ran my business I was
doing it really well like I have a great
business of the best properties but
between what I was and you know friends
some properties to rouse an example
Doral was setting records when I bought
it because I owned it for a period of
time setting records it was going to
there was nothing like I was making a
fortune and then what happened I
announced I'm going to
for office right and all of us as I say
we got to build the wall we're gonna
have borders we're gonna have this we're
gonna have that all of a sudden people
some people didn't like it they thought
the rhetoric was too tough and it went
from doing great to doing five it does
very nicely now it's actually coming
back I understand very strongly but
Doral was setting records and I knew
this would happen most of the stuff that
I have because now instead of having a
hundred percent of the market that loves
you and they love your brand and it's
luxury and it's great now you have 50
percent of the market that's called
politics I fully understood that so it's
cost me between two billion and five
billion dollars and if I had it to do
again I do it in an instant because who
cares if you can afford it what
difference does it make if I had this to
do again because I'm making a big
difference for the country the country
is stronger now that it's been in many
years maybe ever our military's rebuilt
our economy is hitting records as I said
best unemployment numbers best
employment numbers we're strong we're
bringing our soldiers back home from the
endless wars we're doing great
so whether I lost two billion dollars
five billion dollars more or less does
it make any difference to me I don't
care if you're rich it doesn't matter
I'm doing this for the country I'm doing
it for the people that show up I haven't
had an empty seat at a rally I always
say where does the rally it's in a
certain place okay just get the biggest
arena I go into these massive basketball
arenas like in Dallas with the Mavericks
play and fill it up at center record
I've set a record almost every place
I've been because we just need a little
small stage we don't need basketball
courts ice hockey courts and I take less
than musicians because they have bands I
don't have been said the world record
for somebody without a guitar okay I
don't have bands right so that's the
story and you know those people are the
pole and I had great poems I had my best
pals now I think it's because people
think that it's terrible what they're
doing Pelosi
shifty chef
Schumer these people are trying to
destroy the country it's a very bad
thing what they're doing the President
of the United States should be allowed
to run the country not have to focus on
this kind of crap while at the same time
doing a great job on Syria and Turkey
and all of the other things that we're
doing North Korea okay
maybe something but I'll tell you what
if somebody else became president with
that same mindset that they had you'd
right now be at a big war with North
Korea you don't hear too much about it
could happen could happen I don't know I
always say who knows it steals who knows
but in the meantime North Korea's I like
him he likes me we get along I respect
him he respects me you could end up in a
war President Obama told me that he said
the biggest problem I don't know how to
solve it we told me he doesn't matter
solvent I said did you ever call him no
actually he tried 11 times but the man
on the other side the gentleman on the
other side did not take his call okay
lack of respect but he takes my call
thank you very much everybody well look
at other locations I don't think it'll
be as exciting I don't think it'll be as
good it'll cost the country a fortune
because it's very expensive I know
France had a budget of many many
millions of dollars they just did it
they did a great job by the way but
France had a budget of many many
millions of dollars it's going to cost
you no fortune for the country I was
willing to do it for free
but people didn't like that they thought
I may get some promotional value
I need promotional values so badly right
I don't need promotional go ahead what
did you say what else Steve no that's